اقر الكنيست باغلبيه 64 من اعضائه تعيين
يا ريف لذيذ من حزب اللكود رئيسا مؤقتا
للمجلس بعد عزل الرئيس الحليمي كيليدي
المحسوب على حكومه تصريف الاعمال ويسعد
لكود بهذه الخطوه الى السيطره على الكنيست
على نحو يمكنه من تمرير جمله من التعديلات
القانونيه قبل الاعلان عن تشكيل حكومه
جديده في موعد اقصاه الاربعاء المقبل
تاريخ انتهاء المولات الثانيه الممنوحه
لبنيه ميمه
شرقيين في منصب وزاريه رغم ادانته بيتها
من جنائيه اضافه الى تعديلات تمكن عضوي
الكنيسه
المتطرفينو تريتش من توسيع صلاحيات
الممنوحه لهما سواء في وزاره الامن القومي
او وزاره الدفاع
معنى من امام الكنيسه الاسرائيلي في القدس
مراسله الجزيره الياس كرام الياس هل هذه
التعديلات تعتبر محسومه بعد هذا الاجراء
الذي اتخذه الكنيست وما تداعيات ذلك على
الوضع عموما
هي بالفعل محسوبه على اعتبار ان بنيامين
نتنياهو لديه اغلبيه نيابيه من 64
بامكانه ان يقوم بتمرير هذه التعديلات
القانونيه التي ستمكنهم من ارضاء شركاء
توليفته المرتقبه وبالفعل الاعلان في سياق
او في مطلع الاسبوع المقبل عن تمكنه من
تشكيل حكومته السادسه لكنها من شك في ان
هناك انتقادات واسعه سواء كان ذلك في
اوساط المعارضه المستقبليه في اسرائيل او
في اوساط جمعيات حقوقيه اسرائيليه ربما
ستلجا الى تقديم التماسات الى المحكمه
العليا على اعتبار ان هذه التعديلات
القانونيه قد تمت على عجل ومن اجل همم
سياسيه لبنين
النقاش مستفيدا فيها لاسيما وان الحديثه
عن تعديلات تجرى على قوانين اساس يفترض
انها تشكل دستور اسرائيل مستقبليه علما ان
اسرائيل ليس لديها دستور لكن التعديل على
قوانين اساسيه ك- قانون اساس الحكومه التي
تسعى الذي يسعى لاجراء التعديل عليه هو
هذا امر يثير مخاوف المعارضه والتي تقول
بان هذا يعتبر مس خطيرا في الاسس
الديمقراطيه لدوله اسرائيل باليمين يسعى
الى تبييض صفحه درعي شريكه الاساسي في
الحكومه المقبله من اجل تمكينه من ان يشغل
منصبا وزاريا رغم انه مدان بقضيه التهرب
الضريبي التعديل الذي يدخل على هذا
القانون سيتيح له بان يشغل منصبا وزاريا
لان القانون يقول بان اي وزير حكم او اي
شخص حكم وادين بتهمه جنائيه لا يمكن ان
يشغل منصبا وزاريا لسبعه اعوام ولكن هنا
يريدون ان يدخلوا تعديلا يقول انه من اذن
وسجن بشكل فعلي لان الدراي في هذه الحاله
لم يزجن بشكل فرعي فعلي انما فقط اا
اودينا بشكل احترازي ومع وقفي التنفيذ عدا
عن ان التعديلات الاخرى التي يسعى بنيامين
نتنياهو لادخالها تقضي بتوسيع صلاحيات
المتطرفين لتمار بنزين وبتسل ال س مطرج
سواء كان ذلك في همم وزاره الامن القومي
او في وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه وهذه
الصلاحيات الواسعه همم ثمه من يقول بانها
سوف تقود بالفعل الى همم تزايدي العنف
والى انتفاضه الفلسطينيه للثالثه في
الدقيقه في الضفه الغربيه همم المحتله
امام مهله زمنيه قصيره حتى يوم الاربعاء
المقبل من اجل انجازي وتمرير هذه
التعديلات الوزاريه وبعد ذلك عرض حكومته
على الهيئه العامه للكنيسات لنيل الثقه
شكرا
مراسل للجزيره من القدس